wow that was pretty ridiculous so I got
a 16-point 3/4 but as some of you might
have saw I had a PLL skip and for those
of you who don't know what that is this
basically means that um I got to skip a
step of solving the top layer so yeah I
shaved a bunch of seconds off my time
right there and that is going to be my
personal best forever yeah I don't see
myself being at any time soon I have
been practicing as you guys know I'm in
school so I have a lot of studying to do
but I have been practicing a little bit
you know just to it helps me relieve
some stress actually so Rubik's Cube is
good for relieving stress definitely a
little bit of an updating here things
are going pretty well in school I had a
test last week I had a test yesterday I
had two quizzes today I have tests up
the wazoo but I'm thinking of making
some videos coming up pretty soon
hopefully some origami tutorials I know
a lot of you guys wanted to see the ring
I'm thinking of making a double sided
ninja stars and some people said they
wanted to see that possibly a lot of
people were asking about the rose some
people want to see some cube videos let
me know what you want to see the most
I need your guys feedback so close to
comment below let me know what you want
to see the most coming up next I'm also
thinking of doing some possibly some
holiday origami
so keep an eye out for that subscribe if
you're not already and this is Rob I
will see you guys later